SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ALVARADO. GIL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD. CABALLERO
CORTEZ. DALLEY. DODD. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE.
HURTADO JONES. LAIRD. LEMON.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. BOCOBO. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO. SATO.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER.
WILK MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WHAT OUR MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS. BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE.
WE'LL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR GUEST,
CHAPLAIN. FATHER ZAKARIAN. AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR
THE POSTING OF THE COLORS BY THE
MEN, SCOUTS AND PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. FATHER. HONORABLE
STATE SENATORS FROM THE
HEADQUARTERS OF THE WESTERN
DIOCESE OF THE ARMENIAN CHURCH
OF NORTH AMERICA. WE GREET YOU
WITH WHOLE HEARTED AND SINCEREST
WISHES AND COME BEFORE YOU AS
RELIGIOUS SERVANTS AND SONS AND
DAUGHTERS OF Ã NATIONS OF
SURVIVORS, A NATION WHICH
CHAMPIONS DEMOCRACY, PROMOTES
REGIONAL STABILITY, PEACE AND
PROSPERITY. WE COMMEND YOUR
DEDICATION AND ZEALOUS SPIRIT
WITH WHICH YOU SERVE THE
CITIZENS OF THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN THE HOLY BIBLE,
WE ARE INSTRUCTED TO PRAY FOR
OUR LEADERS AS IT IS WITH THIS
GREAT REGARD THAT WE HEED TO
THIS CALLING. LET US ALL BOW OUR
HEADS IN PRAYER. ALMIGHTY GOD,
WE COME BEFORE YOU, BESEECHING
YOUR DIVINE LOVE, MERCY AND
PEACE. BLESS THE MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. GRANT
THEM PEACE, LOVE AND WISDOM TO
SERVE THEIR CONSTITUENTS WITH
UNRELENTING DEDICATION AND
ENDURING AFFECTION. MAY HUMILITY
AND GRACIOUSNESS GUIDE THEM AS
THEY FACE VARIOUS CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR SERVICE,
IN ORDER THAT THEY MAY EMBRACE
KINDNESS, COMPASSION, AND
JUSTICE. AMEN. AMEN THANK YOU.
SCOUTS. SCOUTS, PLEASE POST THE
COLORS
.
MEMBERS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE, WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
SCOUTS, PLEASE RETIRE TO THE
COLORS
.
THANK YOU.
YES. ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE WILL TAKE UP THE
FOLLOWING RESOLUTIONS. OUT OF
ORDER S.R. 83 AND SCR 183. AFTER
ADOPTION OF EACH RESOLUTION WILL
RETURN TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR FOR AUTHORS TO INTRODUCE
THEIR GUESTS. UNDER PRIVILEGE OF
THE FLOOR. WE'RE RECOGNIZING
SENATORS WILKES WIFE AT THIS
TIME, VANESSA SAFFARIAN WILK.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING TO SENATE
THIRD READING. WE HAVE FILED
ITEM 31 SR 83 BY SENATOR WILK.
HE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ SENATE RESOLUTION 83 BY
SENATOR WILK. RELATIVE TO THE
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THE TRAGEDY OF
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE OF 1950
THROUGH 1923. SENATOR WILK, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, AS A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE ARMENIAN
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS, IT PAINS ME
TO BE INTRODUCING SR 83,
COMMEMORATING THE 100TH AND
NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE OF 1915, 109
YEARS HAVE PASSED. THOSE WHO
LIVED THROUGH THAT PERIOD ARE
NOW DEAD, AND THE ARMENIAN
PEOPLE HAVE YET TO RECEIVE THE
ACKNOWLEDGMENT FROM THOSE
RESPONSIBLE, EVEN WORSE IS STILL
GOING ON TODAY. BEGINNING IN
1915, MORE THAN 1.5 MILLION
ARMENIANS WERE SYSTEMATICALLY
EXTERMINATED DURING THE FIRST
GENOCIDE OF MODERN TIMES. IN
ADDITION TO THE ARMENIANS, THE
BLOODS OF TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
GREEKS AND ASSYRIANS WERE SHED
BY THE OTTOMAN TURKS AS WELL.
DESPITE THE DOCUMENTED CARNAGE
AND HISTORICAL EVIDENCE, THE
TURKISH GOVERNMENT HAS NEVER
ACKNOWLEDGED OR TAKEN
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT HAPPENED
IN 2008. THEN SENATOR BARACK
OBAMA STATED, QUOTE, THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE IS NOT AN
ACCUSATION. A PERSONAL OPINION
OR A POINT OF VIEW. IT IS A
WIDELY DOCUMENTED FACT,
SUPPORTED BY AN OVERWHELMING
BODY OF HISTORICAL AND
HISTORICAL EVIDENCE. END QUOTE
AND ON APRIL 24TH, 2021, SENATOR
JOE, EXCUSE ME, PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN BECAME THE FIRST US
PRESIDENT TO DECLARE THE FORMAL
RECOGNITION OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE. WHILE THE WHILE THE
ARMENIAN PEOPLE ARE APPRECIATIVE
OF THE ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THEIR
HISTORY, YET ANOTHER POGROM
AGAINST THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE IS
OCCURRING TODAY ON SEPTEMBER
13TH, 2022. TURKEY'S ALLY
AZERBAIJAN LAUNCHED AN
UNPROVOKED ASSAULT ON THE
SOVEREIGN ARMENIAN TERRITORY
WITH INTENSE SHELLING AND DRONE
ATTACKS ON NAGORNO-KARABAKH,
ALSO KNOWN AS THE REPUBLIC OF
ARTSAKH. IN THE FOLLOWING WEEKS
AND MONTHS, THE AZERBAIJANI
TROOPS BOMBED TOWNS AND
CHURCHES, ESTABLISHED A BLOCKADE
PREVENTING FOOD AND MEDICINE
FROM BEING DELIVERED, AND
ULTIMATELY FORCED THE RELOCATION
OF OVER 100,000 ARMENIANS LIVING
IN ARTSAKH. BECAUSE OF ARMENIANS
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION IN THE
WORLD, IT DOESN'T HOLD A, QUOTE,
NATIONAL VITAL INTEREST, END
QUOTE, FOR THE US GOVERNMENT.
THUS, LITTLE IS BEING DONE TO
PROTECT THE FREEDOMS AND
PROPERTY OF THOSE ARMENIANS THAT
WERE FORCED TO FLEE. I PRAY THAT
THE WORLD COMMUNITY WILL
UNDERSTAND THE MORAL IMPERATIVE
OF ENSURING THAT A FREE PEOPLE
REMAIN FREE, AND THAT A PEACEFUL
SOLUTION IS REACHED. THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY 10 MILLION
ARMENIANS IN THE WORLD, WITH
ABOUT 3 MILLION LIVING IN
COUNTRY, AND THE REMAINING 7
MILLION BEING PART OF THE
DIASPORA. DESPITE BEING
SCATTERED THROUGHOUT THE GLOBE,
THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO RETAIN THEIR CULTURE AND
THRIVE IN WHICHEVER COUNTRY THEY
SETTLE IN PRIOR YEARS. I TOLD
THE INCREDIBLE STORY OF MY WIFE,
VANESSA'S GREAT AUNT, WHO
WITNESSED THE MURDER OF HER
HUSBAND AT THE HANDS OF THE
OTTOMAN TURKS. THE STARVATION
AND DEATH OF HER YOUNG CHILDREN,
INCLUDING AN INFANT DURING ONE
OF THE FAMOUS DESERT DEATH
MARCHES AND SHE WAS RAPED AND
LEFT FOR DEAD IN A PILE OF
CORPSES IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
DESERT. HOWEVER, SHE FAKED HER
DEATH, ESCAPED, AND WAS REUNITED
WITH HER TWO BROTHERS IN
WATERTOWN, MASSACHUSETTS. ON THE
FLOOR WITH US TODAY ARE SOME OF
MY FAMILY MEMBERS, INCLUDING MY
MOTHER IN LAW, ALICE BOYAN. AND
SO I'M GOING TO TAKE THIS SINCE
IT'S MY LAST TIME DOING THIS IN
THE SENATE, I'M GOING TO TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT HER
HUSBAND. ORGANIC POISON. SO
ORGANIC. FAMILY HAILED FROM THE
AVON REGION OF HISTORICAL
ARMENIA. IN FACT, VANESSA IS
NAMED AFTER HER ANCESTRAL
HOMELAND. JENNIE'S PARENTS WERE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO ESCAPE THE
GENOCIDE AND IMMIGRATED TO
RUSSIA. ASNYK WAS BORN IN
RUSSIA, BUT THEN THE BOLSHEVIK
REVOLUTION FORCED THE FAMILY TO
FLEE ONCE AGAIN, AND THEY
EVENTUALLY SETTLED IN TEHRAN,
IRAN. AT 18, GALGIANI CAME BY
BOAT TO AMERICA TO ATTEND
COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY. WHEN HE
REGISTERED AT ELLIS ISLAND, THE
IMMIGRATION OFFICER DIDN'T KNOW
HOW TO SPELL ORGANIC, SO HE
ASKED HIM TO TAKE ON AN AMERICAN
NAME. HARRY TRUMAN WAS PRESIDENT
AT THAT TIME, SO ORGANIC
REGISTERED AS A HARRY SAVOYARD.
LIKE MOST IMMIGRANTS, HARRY HAD
A DEEPER UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
IT IS TO BE AN AMERICAN THAN
MOST OF THOSE BORN HERE. HE
LOVED AMERICA AND ARMENIA
EQUALLY. IN FACT, HARRY
IMMEDIATELY SIGNED UP FOR THE
ROTC PROGRAM AT COLUMBIA, BUT HE
WAS DISMISSED FROM THE PROGRAM
DURING WEEK SIX WHEN THE OFFICER
REALIZED THAT HE WAS NOT A US
CITIZEN. HARRY EVENTUALLY
RELOCATED TO BOSTON, WHERE HE
EARNED A BACHELOR'S FROM BOSTON
COLLEGE AND A MASTER'S AND PHD
FROM BOSTON UNIVERSITY. HARRY
AND HIS WIFE, ALICE, HAD A HOME
AT 50 BAILEY ROAD IN WATERTOWN,
MASSACHUSETTS, WHICH IS
MASSACHUSETTS VERSION OF
GLENDALE, WHERE THEY RAISED
THEIR THREE CHILDREN IN THEIR
HOME. BECAME THE FIRST HOME FOR
MANY ARMENIANS WHO IMMIGRATED TO
THE US SEEKING A BETTER LIFE.
HARRY WOULD FIND THEM JOBS AND
ALICE WOULD HOST WEEKLY DINNERS
FOR THE RECENT IMMIGRANTS COULD
BUILD COMMUNITY IN THEIR NEW
COUNTRY. SO DESPITE THE TURKS
BEST EFFORTS THEY ARE MEETING,
PEOPLE HAVE NOT ONLY SURVIVED,
BUT THEY HAVE THRIVED WHEREVER
THEY HAVE GONE. I CLOSE WITH
WORDS SPOKEN BY CANADIAN
CANADIAN PRIME MINISTER JUSTIN
TRUDEAU AT AN ARMENIAN GENOCIDE
CEREMONY ON APRIL 24TH, 2022,
QUOTE, HATRED AND VIOLENCE MUST
NEVER AGAIN BE MET WITH
INDIFFERENCE. EACH AND EVERY ONE
OF US HAS A ROLE TO PLAY IN
MAKING SURE SUCH BRUTALITY IS
NEVER REPEATED. AND IT STARTS
WITH TAKING A STAND AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION AND HATE IN ALL
FORMS. WHEN WHENEVER AND
WHEREVER IT OCCURS TOGETHER ON
THIS SOMBER ANNIVERSARY, WE
REMEMBER THE LIVES, LOSS,
RECOGNIZE THE STRENGTH IN THE
SPIRIT OF THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE,
AND LOOK FORWARD WITH HOPE TO A
FUTURE OF PEACE. MUTUAL RESPECT
AND DIGNITY AMONG PEOPLE AND
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD IS
WITH THIS HOPE IN MY HEART THAT
THESE WORDS FROM PRIME MINISTER
TRUDEAU COME TO PASS FOR ALL
PEOPLE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON SR 83. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF THE
DEBATE, SENATOR DURAZZO? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN AND WILL
ALWAYS BE A PLACE WHERE THOSE
WHO ARE TORN FROM THEIR
HOMELANDS CAN COME AND MAKE A
NEW HOME. THE ARMENIAN STORY IS
PART OF THE GREATER CALIFORNIA
STORY. I AM PROUD TO REPRESENT
LITTLE ARMENIA AND MY DISTRICT,
WHERE SO MANY ARMENIANS HAVE
CALLED IT HOME FOR DECADES.
TODAY, OUR SYMPATHY GOES TO ALL
SURVIVORS OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE. THERE CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN, AND ESPECIALLY
THE NEARLY HALF A MILLION PEOPLE
OF ARMENIAN DESCENT WHO ARE PART
OF OUR STATE TODAY. WE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS,
CGRTS AND DEDICATION OF THE
DESCENDANTS OF THE GENOCIDE
VICTIMS WHO CONTINUE TO FIGHT
FOR JUSTICE AND PLAY A VITAL
ROLE IN CALIFORNIA'S ADVANCEMENT
. THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WILL NOT LET THEIR HISTORY
VANISH, AND IT WILL NOT LET
THEIR DEMAND FOR JUSTICE GO
UNANSWERED. IN OUR OWN COUNTRY,
WE HAVE RECOGNIZED THE WRONGS
DONE TO OUR OWN INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE. AMERICA IS A NATION OF
ETHICS. WE KNOW THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN RIGHT AND WRONG, AND WE
TAKE TAKE ACTION TO SIDE WITH
SUFFERING POPULATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD. WE CAN DO NO LESS NOW
THAN TO CONDEMN THE ACTIONS OF
TURKEY AND AZERBAIJAN, TO WIPE
EVEN THE MEMORY OF THE ARMENIANS
OFF THE FACE OF THE EARTH. I
CALL UPON ALL MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL TO
CONDEMN THE AZERI AND TURKISH
GOVERNMENTS FROM THEIR CONTINUED
GENOCIDE AGAINST THE ARMENIAN
PEOPLE, AND URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
SR 83. THANK YOU, SENATOR MANN.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
AS WELL IN SUPPORT OF SR 83. AND
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA CLARITA FOR BRINGING
FORWARD THIS CRUCIAL RESOLUTION
RECOGNIZING THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE OF 1915 TO 1923 AS HOME
TO THE LARGEST ARMENIAN AMERICAN
POPULATION IN THE UNITED STATES.
CALIFORNIA'S RECOGNITION OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE IS CRUCIAL. AS
THE PHILOSOPHER GEORGE SANTAYANA
SAID, THOSE WHO CANNOT REMEMBER
THE PAST ARE DOOMED TO REPEAT IT
, AND SO WE MUST PERSEVERE IN
REMEMBERING THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE, BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
MANY PARALLELS TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE UNITED STATES
TODAY. MUCH LIKE THE UNITED
STATES, THE OTTOMAN EMPIRE WAS A
GREAT NATION STATE BASED ON A
LONG TRADITION OF
MULTICULTURALISM AND RELIGIOUS
TOLERANCE. BUT AS IT BEGAN TO
FALTER ON THE WORLD STAGE, IT
BECAME TAKEN OVER BY A HYPER
NATIONALIST REGIME THAT
DEMONIZED AND MARGINALIZED
MINORITY COMMUNITIES, INCLUDING
NOT ONLY THE ARMENIANS, BUT ALSO
GREEKS AND ASSYRIANS. THIS
EVENTUALLY LED TO THE HORRORS
THAT WE NOW KNOW AS THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE, WHERE OVER 1.5 MILLION
ARMENIANS WERE SYSTEMATICALLY
EXTERMINATED IN THIS HORRIFIC
GENOCIDE WAS LARGELY IGNORED BY
THE REST OF THE WORLD AND THEN
MOSTLY FORGOTTEN. AND THIS LED
DIRECTLY TO THE INSPIRATION OF
ADOLF HITLER, WHO FAMOUSLY SAID,
WHO, AFTER ALL, SPEAKS TODAY OF
THE ANNIHILATION, ANNIHILATION
OF THE ARMENIANS AND JUSTIFYING
THE ATROCITIES OF HIS OWN
REGIME, IT IS ESSENTIAL TO
REMEMBER THIS AS WE SEE THAT
ALARMING RISE OF
AUTHORITARIANISM AND HYPER
NATIONALISM ACROSS THE WORLD,
INCLUDING HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES. SO TO TRULY HONOR THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE, WE MUST
CONTINUE TO RECOGNIZE IT AND
STAND UP AGAINST GENOCIDE
EVERYWHERE, INCLUDING THE
ATTACKS ON ARTSAKH BY THE
TURKISH GOVERNMENT AND ITS
PROXIES. SO I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AGAIN AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY
AS A PROUD COAUTHOR OF SENATE
BILL OR SENATE RESOLUTION 83,
COMMEMORATING THE ANNIVERSARY OF
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. AND UP ON
THE BALCONY, WE HAVE SO MANY
ARMENIAN LEADERS WHO HAVE COME
TOGETHER FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA TO BE ACKNOWLEDGED
AND TO PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S
HISTORICAL DAY SANCTIONED BY THE
OTTOMAN EMPIRE IN 1915, THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE WAS THE FIRST
STATE SPONSORED GENOCIDE IN
MODERN HISTORY AND MODERN TIMES.
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES WERE FORCIBLY
MARCHED TO THEIR DEATH OR
MURDERED IN AN ATTEMPT TO ERASE
THEIR PRESENCE FROM A REGION
THEY HAD LIVED IN PEACEFULLY FOR
YEARS AND YEARS. OVER 4000 YEARS
OF. MATTER OF FACT, CALIFORNIA
IS HOME. YOU'VE HEARD TO THE
LARGEST ARMENIAN AMERICAN,
ARMENIAN POPULATION IN THE
UNITED STATES, AND WE'RE SO
PROUD OF IT. HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
ARMENIAN COMMUNITY TO ENSURE
FUTURE GENERATIONS LEARN FROM
THIS GENOCIDE AND PREVENT THE
ATROCITY. LIKE THIS FROM EVER
HAPPENING AGAIN. I AM ETERNALLY
GRATEFUL TO THE ARMENIAN
COMMUNITY AND THE ARMENIAN
AMERICANS THAT ARE HERE TODAY
THAT HAVE WORKED SO HARD TO SEE
US COME TOGETHER HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND TO THEIR
DESCENDANTS AND SURVIVORS ACROSS
THE GLOBE FOR THEIR PERSEVERANCE
AND THEIR DEDICATION, THEIR
DEDICATION TO THE ARMENIAN CAUSE
. IN ORDER FOR US TO PRESENT TO
ALL OF YOU A HEARTFELT
CONDOLENCES AND CERTAINLY THE
FACT THAT WE BELIEVE IN THE
CAUSE. YOU'RE HERE TODAY BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT YOU WILL NOT
NOT LET ANYONE FORGET AS WE MUST
NOT EVER FORGET, THE INJUSTICE
BEFALLEN UPON YOUR ANCESTORS.
THERE MUST BE A COMPLETE AND
ACCURATE ACCOUNTING OF HISTORY,
AND ONLY THEN CAN WE PREVENT
ISSUES LIKE THIS. ATROCITIES
LIKE THIS THAT EVER HAPPENED
AGAIN IN MODERN TIMES OR EVER IN
OUR HISTORY OR IN OUR FUTURE. IN
MY OWN DISTRICT, THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE MARTYRS MONUMENT SERVES
AS A BEACON FOR ARMENIANS AROUND
THE COUNTRY, AND IT'S IMPORTANT
AND IT CANNOT. WE CANNOT STOP
FROM HAVING PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THE GENOCIDE AND WHAT TOOK
PLACE. THAT'S WHY THAT ARMENIAN
MONUMENT IS THERE, TO EDUCATE
AND TO CONTINUE GETTING EVERYONE
TO STOP BY AND PAY CONDOLENCES,
AND ALWAYS TO REMEMBER THE
MARTYRS WHO SURVIVED, THE
MARTYRS WHO LOST THEIR LIVES,
AND CERTAINLY THOSE RIGHT NOW
WHO WILL NOT EVER LET US FORGET
GOD BLESS YOU ALL. THANK YOU.
AND I AM IN TOTAL SUPPORT OF SR
83. THANK YOU, SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS,
I AM DEEPLY HONORED TO RISE TO
SUPPORT SCR 83 AND MARK THE
109TH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE ON OUR SENATE
FLOOR TODAY AND TO REAFFIRM OUR
STRONG AND UNWAVERING COMMITMENT
TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO RECOGNIZE AND
REMEMBER THE FIRST GENOCIDE OF
THE 20TH CENTURY. I ESPECIALLY
WANT TO COMMEND MY FRIEND, THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM SANTA CLARITA,
WHO HAS BEEN A TIRELESS ADVOCATE
FOR THE ARMENIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND THE POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
AND ARMENIA. THE SENATOR HAS
DONE TREMENDOUS GOOD WORK, AND
HE HAS ALWAYS DONE IT WITHOUT
FANFARE, ALWAYS IN THE
BACKGROUND AND ALWAYS DOING IT
FROM THE HEART. AND I JUST KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA WILL MISS THIS
OUTSTANDING LEADER FROM SANTA
CLARITA. AND I'M SO PLEASED THAT
THE SEQUOIA AND EXTENDED FAMILY
IS HERE TO SHARE IN THIS SOLEMN
DAY IN SUPPORT OF MY COLLEAGUE,
BUT ALSO IN THE RECOGNITION OF
THIS IMPORTANT, GENOCIDE
RESOLUTION THAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US. AS IT'S BEEN SAID, FROM 1915
TO 1923, THE OTTOMAN, THE
OTTOMAN EMPIRE SYSTEMATICALLY
TARGETED AND EXTERMINATED
ARMENIAN MEN, WOMEN AND
CHILDREN, ALONG WITH COUNTLESS
ASSYRIANS, GREEKS AND OTHER
ETHNIC AND RELIGIOUS MINORITIES.
THE THE GENOCIDE RESULTED IN THE
DEATH OF OVER 1.5 MILLION
ARMENIANS. LET ME SAY THAT
AGAIN. 1.5 MILLION PEOPLE WERE
SLAUGHTERED. NOW, THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY'S
FAILURE TO PUNISH THE
PERPETRATORS AND THE DENIERS OF
THE FIRST GENOCIDE, THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE, AND THE SUBSEQUENT
POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC AND
MILITARY SUPPORT FOR THE ERDOGAN
AND ALIYEV'S DICTATORIAL REGIMES
HAVE ONLY EMBOLDENED TURKEY AND
AZERBAIJAN TO CONTINUE THEIR
GENOCIDAL ACTIONS. THIS YEAR,
OUR REFLECTIONS ARE DEEPENED BY
THE RECENT EVENTS IN
NAGORNO-KARABAKH. THE BELOVED
ARTSAKH IN 2023, AZERBAIJAN,
BACKED BY TURKEY, PERPETRATED AN
ETHNIC CLEANSING CAMPAIGN
AGAINST THE ARMENIANS OF ARTSAKH
, RESULTING IN THE LOSS OF
COUNTLESS LIVES. THE DESTRUCTION
OF CULTURAL AND RELIGIOUS SITES,
AND THE FORCED EXODUS OF 120,000
ETHNIC ARMENIANS OF ARTSAKH. A
WONDERFUL HISTORIC CATHEDRAL IN
SHUSHI, WHERE I ATTENDED A
WEDDING, IS SADLY NO MORE A
HOUSE OF WORSHIP AND FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN A THOUSAND YEARS,
ARTSAKH IS LEFT WITHOUT ITS
INDIGENOUS ETHNIC ARMENIAN
POPULATION. FORMER INTERNATIONAL
CRIMINAL COURT PROSECUTOR LUIS
MORENO OCAMPO AND JUAN MENDEZ,
WHO WAS THE FIRST UN AMBASSADOR
ON GENOCIDE PREVENTION, PUT THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY ON HIGH
ALERT. MANY TIMES SHOWING THE
CIRCUMSTANCES BY WHICH
AZERBAIJAN'S ACTIONS HAVE
CONSTITUTED GENOCIDE. TODAY.
TODAY, THREE THREE FORMER
ARTSAKH PRESIDENTS AND FIVE
OTHER COMMUNITY LEADERS ARE
STILL IN INCARCERATED IN
AZERBAIJAN, ONE OF WHOM I HOSTED
IN MY OFFICE IN GLENDALE AND
THEN WHO HOSTED ME IN ARTSAKH,
IS STILL ILLEGALLY BEHIND BARS
TODAY. THE NINE MONTH BLOCKADE
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT DEPRIVED
FOOD, WATER AND MEDICINE FROM
ARTSAKH. AND THE CAPTIVITY OF
THE OFFICIALS IS A MESSAGE FROM
AZERBAIJAN TO ARMENIANS THAT
THEY CANNOT LIVE ON THEIR
HISTORIC LAND, THAT THEY WILL BE
STARVED, INCARCERATED AND
KILLED. SO EMBEDDED IN A 1948
UNIVERSAL DECLARATION OF HUMAN
RIGHTS AT THE FOURTH GENEVA
CONVENTION ON HUMAN RIGHTS, TO
WHICH AZERBAIJAN IS A SIGNATORY,
IT STATES, NO ONE SHALL BE
DEPRIVED OF THE RETURN TO THEIR
TERRITORY FREE. NO ONE SHOULD BE
DEPRIVED, BUT HERE WE HAVE
120,000 PEOPLE DRIVEN FROM THEIR
HOMES, GARDENS, CULTURAL AND
HISTORIC SITES, FORCED TO PACK
WHATEVER THEY COULD FIT INTO
THEIR CARS OR IN THEIR BACKPACK
AND FLEE ARTSAKH TO SAVE THEIR
LIVES. SO, SADLY AND TRAGICALLY,
MANY OF THESE GOOD PEOPLE, IT'S
BEEN TOLD, STILL HOLD ON TO THE
KEYS OF THEIR HOMES WITH THE
HOPE OF SOMEDAY TO RETURN. SO
THE US MUST ENSURE VÀ MUST
ENSURE THE RIGHT OF ARMENIANS TO
RETURN TO ARTSAKH UNDER A SAFE
CONDITION. AND IT CAN BE ARGUED
STRONGLY THAT BECAUSE THE FIRST
GENOCIDE PERPETRATED AGAINST
ETHNIC ARMENIANS WENT
UNPUBLISHED, UNPUNISHED A
CENTURY AGO, THE SAME VIOLENT
PEOPLE ARE REPEATING THEIR
ILLEGAL AND HUMAN ACTS TODAY,
AND AS IT'S BEEN SAID, THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE WAS USED AS A
ROAD MAP FOR FUTURE GENOCIDES.
AND WE STILL HAVE TODAY IN THE
CAPITAL TODAY, GENOCIDE DENIERS
WALKING THE HALLS SAYING THIS
DID NOT HAPPEN. THAT'S TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA. NHÀ SO TURKEY AND
AZERBAIJAN CONTINUE THEIR
AGGRESSION AGAINST ARMENIANS AND
ARMENIA WITH ATTACKS ON THE
BORDER AND REPEATED AND REGULAR
GENOCIDAL RHETORIC. SO THE US
WAS SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE PEACE.
RUSSIA WAS SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE
PEACE. FRANCE WAS SUPPOSED TO
PROVIDE PEACE. AND HERE WE HAVE
120,000 PEOPLE DRIVEN FROM THEIR
HOME AND GENOCIDE DENIERS
WALKING THE HALLS OF OUR
CAPITAL. SO WE MUST DO MORE TO
HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR OBLIGATION, FOR THEIR
ACTIONS. WE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION TO NOT JUST CONDEMN
THE GENOCIDE AND VIOLATIONS OF
HUMAN RIGHTS, BUT TO COMMAND TO
DEMAND JUSTICE, BECAUSE WITHOUT
PEACE THERE IS NO JUSTICE AND
WITHOUT RECOGNITION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY, THERE IS NO
PEACE THAT IS ONCE AGAIN WHY I
CALL ON THE STATE DEPARTMENT TO
END US MILITARY AID TO
AZERBAIJAN, SANCTION AZERBAIJANI
OFFICIALS FOR THEIR HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS, ENSURE THE RIGHT OF
RETURN FOR THE FORCIBLY
DISPLACED. SO DESPITE THESE
HORRORS, THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE
HAVE PERSISTED AND REBUILT THEIR
COUNTRY, CONTRIBUTED TO
IMMEASURABLE PROGRESS AND
POSITIVE REACTIONS AND POSITIVE
INTERACTIONS IN THE UNITED
STATES, IN PARTICULAR HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, WHERE OUR STATE IS
HOME TO THE LARGEST ARMENIAN
AMERICAN POPULATION IN THE US,
AND OBVIOUSLY IN THE 25TH SENATE
DISTRICT, IT IS A VIBRANT,
THRIVING COMMUNITY, AND MANY
COMMUNITY LEADERS ARE HERE TODAY
TO MOURN WITH US AND TO
RECOGNIZE WITH US. SO I'M
HONORED TO REPRESENT THIS
COMMUNITY. I STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE COMMUNITY TODAY. I
HARKEN BACK TO MY VISITS TO
ARTSAKH, BOTH PRE AND POST WAR,
AND HOW THAT COUNTRY CHANGED SO
MUCH BASED ON THE AGGRESSION,
THE VIOLENCE, AND THE MEAN
SPIRITED ETHNIC CLEANSING THAT
AZERBAIJAN IS PERPETRATING. AND
SO WE REMEMBER THE RESILIENCE OF
THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE. WE REAFFIRM
OUR COMMITMENT TO THEM, OUR LOVE
FOR THEM, AND OUR RECOGNITION OF
THE GENOCIDE. AND WE ALSO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WILL NEVER, EVER
FORGET WHAT HAPPENED BEGINNING
IN 1915. SO YOUR BANK CHECK
MARANA, WHICH MEANS WE WILL
NEVER FORGET. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE OF AYE ON SR 83.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? DEBATE PRESIDENT PRO
TEM MCGUIRE, THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. PRESIDENT. AND MR.
PRESIDENT, TODAY I RISE
ALONGSIDE OUR COLLEAGUES FROM
THE ARMENIAN CAUCUS IN SUPPORT
OF SR 83 AND TO BE ABLE TO
COMMEMORATE THE 109TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE, I WANT TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUES, ESPECIALLY SENATORS
WILK, WHO DELIVERED SUCH A
PASSIONATE ADDRESS TO THIS BODY,
ALONG WITH SENATOR DURAZZO AND
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND ALL THE
MEMBERS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE FOR THEIR WORK, THEIR WORK
TO BE ABLE TO REMEMBER THE
HORRIFIC TRAGEDY AND ENSURING
THAT NO ONE ON THIS PLANET EVER
FORGETS. YOU KNOW, THE HISTORY
IS CLEAR. THE GENOCIDE OF THE
ARMENIAN PEOPLE WILL BE
SUSTAINED IN THE HISTORY BOOKS
FOREVER, AND THE INCIDENTS THAT
OCCURRED RESULTED IN THE MASS
KILLINGS. WE'VE HEARD OF 1.5
MILLION ARMENIANS IN THEIR
HOMELAND. WE CAN'T LET HISTORY
REPEAT ITSELF. THE ARMENIAN
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO FACE
PERSECUTION AND VIOLENCE AT HOME
, AND AMERICA MUST STAND WITH
THE PEOPLE OF ARMENIA TO DEFEND
DEMOCRACY AND TO BE ABLE TO
STAND UP AGAINST HATE AND TO
STAND UP AGAINST VIOLENCE. AND
WE'RE HONORED BY OUR ESTEEMED
GUESTS WHO HAVE GATHERED WITH US
TODAY. AND WE WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT CALIFORNIA, THE
GOLDEN STATE, STANDS WITH THE
ARMENIAN PEOPLE, AND WE STAND
WITH THE MEMBERS WHO CALL THIS
GREAT STATE HOME. MR. PRESIDENT
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON SR 83. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? SEEING NO
MICROPHONES. SENATOR WILK, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. FIRST OF
ALL, I WANT TO THANK ALL MEMBERS
FOR SHARING THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS ISSUE. I WANT TO GIVE A
SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO THE SENATOR
FROM BURBANK FOR THE KIND WORDS
ABOUT MY SERVICE IN IN THIS
ARENA AND ALSO FOR THE EXCELLENT
HIS HIS HISTORY LESSON THAT YOU
GAVE EVERYBODY HERE TODAY. AND I
REALLY I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP THROUGH THE
YEARS US WORKING TOGETHER ON THE
ARMENIAN ARMENIAN CAUCUS. AND
YOU'VE BEEN ACTUALLY ON THE
FRONT LINES IN ARTSAKH NUMEROUS
TIMES AND WANT TO REALLY THANK
YOU FOR THAT. AND IT WAS
MENTIONED FROM THE CENTER FOR
ORANGE COUNTY AND OTHERS ABOUT
HOW WE SHOULD NEVER FORGET. SO I
WANT TO THANK THIS BODY, BECAUSE
EVERY YEAR WE BRING THIS UP AND
WE PROCLAIM THAT THIS IS NOT
RIGHT, BUT IF WE DON'T CONTINUE
TO DO THAT, IT WILL HAPPEN
AGAIN. I'VE HAD THE EXPERIENCE
TWICE OF GOING TO YEREVAN,
ARMENIA AND TOURING THE GENOCIDE
MUSEUM. AND WHEN YOU SEE ALL THE
PHOTOS OF THE OTTOMAN TURKS,
WHO'S RIGHT STANDING THERE WITH
THEM? GERMAN SOLDIERS, AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER FOR THE
PLAYBOOK FOR GENOCIDE, WAS
CONDUCTED THERE IN ARMENIA. AND
IT CONTINUES TO BE ACTED OUT
TODAY. SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
STAND UP AND WE ADVOCATE AND WE
EDUCATE WITH THAT. ANYTIME I
MEET AN ARMENIAN, I ALWAYS TELL
THEM I'M AN ABC AND THEY GO,
WHAT'S AN ABC? AND I SAID,
ARMENIAN BY CHOICE. SO I HOPE
ALL OF YOU TODAY WILL BE AN ABC
BY VOTING YES ON SR 83. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM 31. ELLEN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE
BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR, I BRADFORD
. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ
AYE. DALLY I DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLASER. I.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO I JONES. AYE LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR.
I'M IN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
AYE. NHIÀU AYE. OCHOA. BOGH.
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. RATH AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN LIMÓN
STERN. AYES 37. NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. SENATOR
WILK, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AS MENTIONED
BY THE SENATOR FROM MONTEBELLO,
WE HAVE MANY ARMENIAN LEADERS
HERE TODAY, BUT I'M JUST GOING
TO INTRODUCE A FEW OF THEM. I
WANT TO START WITH MY MOTHER IN
LAW, ALICE, 97 YEARS YOUNG. MY
BROTHER IN LAW, GREG SAVOYEN. MY
WIFE, MY WIFE JES. MY NIECE
SYDNEY, WITH HER BOYFRIEND TAZ.
ROSS AND TAZ GOT A HAIRCUT JUST
FOR TODAY, SO THAT'S VERY
IMPRESSIVE. ALSO WITH US TODAY
WE HAVE GLENDALE MAYOR ALAN
ASTERION. AND I'M SURE MOST OF
US KNOW HIM. HY BAGDASARIAN, THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY AND CHIEF
COUNSEL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND AG. AND
NONE OF US BE POSSIBLE WITHOUT
REALLY THE HEARTBEAT OF THE
ARMENIAN CAUCUS. AND THAT'S
NATALIE BROUGHTON. HE INVOKED
VULCAN THAT IT'S HARD TO SAY. WE
HAVE MEMBERS FROM THE ARMENIAN
NATIONAL COMMITTEE OF AMERICA,
MEMBERS FROM THE ARMENIAN
ASSEMBLY OF AMERICA, AND THE
PERSON WHO LED US IN PRAYER
TODAY WAS THE PERSON WHO
CHRISTENED ME IN THE ARMENIAN
APOSTOLIC CHURCH. FATHER
REVEREND FATHER KRIKOR ZAKARIAN.
AND WITH THAT, WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A QUICK
PHOTO AND THEN ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WHO WANT TO JOIN, WE'D LOVE TO
HAVE YOU IN IT. THANK YOU. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE, WE WELCOME EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF YOU. NOW IS THE
TIME FOR THE PHOTO. I'M SORRY.
MR. MR. PRESIDENT, THE SENATOR
FROM RIVERSIDE SAID I SHOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE MY ARMENIAN BRIDE
ONCE AGAIN. SO VANESSA AND WILK.
WELCOME TO ALL
.
ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS. 30S. 30S.
OUR MEMBERS WERE READY TO RETURN
TO THE BUSINESS AT HAND. NEXT
UP, ON THE PRIVILEGE OF THE
FLOOR, SENATOR ROTH WILL
INTRODUCE GUEST. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SENATORS, YOU MAY
HAVE NOTICED THAT WE HAVE
HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS VISITING
SACRAMENTO TODAY FOR THEIR
IGNITE THE CAPITAL ADVOCACY DAY.
THIS IS THE GENERATION THAT WILL
LEAD US INTO THE NEXT CHAPTER OF
THE 21ST CENTURY. I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ALL OF THE
INCREDIBLE WORK, ABSOLUTELY
INCREDIBLE WORK THAT IGNITE DOES
TO HELP YOUNG WOMEN DISCOVER AND
FLEX THEIR POLITICAL POWER AND
FOR ENABLING SO MANY TO VISIT US
IN THE CAPITOL TODAY, I'M VERY
PROUD TO WELCOME AND INTRODUCE
IGNITE MEMBERS FROM THE 31ST
SENATE DISTRICT WHO WERE HERE
ADVOCATING FOR THEIR COMMUNITY,
AS WELL AS FOR YOUNG WOMEN
AROUND THE STATE FROM HOME
GARDENS ACADEMY AND THE LETHA
RANEY INTERMEDIATE SCHOOL IN
CORONA. SENATORS, HOW ABOUT
GIVING THEM A WARM SENATE
WELCOME UP HERE IN THE GALLERY?
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. CONTINUING WITH
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR, WE WANT
TO NEXT RECOGNIZE SENATOR
BRADFORD. SENATOR BRADFORD, FROM
THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. IT'S
TRULY MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE A
GROUP OF REMARKABLE STUDENTS AND
FACULTY AND ADMINISTRATION FROM
JUNIPERO SERRA HIGH SCHOOL IN
GARDENA, IN THE HEART OF MY
DISTRICT, HIGH SCHOOL IS JUST
LESS THAN A MILE FROM MY HOME.
JUNIPERO SERRA HIGH SCHOOL IS A
CATHOLIC INSTITUTION IN GARDENA,
FOUNDED IN 1950 AND HAS A RICH
TRADITION OF EXCELLENCE IN
EDUCATION. 97% OF THEIR
POPULATION ARE STUDENTS OF COLOR
WHO COME FROM ALL ACROSS LA
COUNTY. SIERRA IS ONE A FEW
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE NATION, AND
THE FIRST SCHOOL OF COLOR TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE INTERNATIONAL
SPACE STATION PROGRAM. FOR THE
SECOND YEAR IN A ROW, THESE HARD
WORKING AND INTELLIGENT YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE SPENT COUNTLESS
HOURS THAT HAVE CULMINATED IN
SENDING AN EXPERIMENT ABOARD THE
INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION.
THEIR EXPERIENCE LAUNCHED JUST
LAST MONTH FROM KENNEDY SPACE
CENTER IN FLORIDA TO THE
INTERNATIONAL SPACE CENTER ON
BOARD STATION. I SHOULD SAY, ON
BOARD THE SPACEX FALCON NINE
ROCKET, WHICH TWO WAS BUILT IN
MY DISTRICT JUST A MILE OR SO
AWAY FROM THE HIGH SCHOOL ITSELF
, SPONSORED BY THE NONPROFIT
QUEST INSTITUTE FOR QUALITY
EDUCATION IN SAN JOSE THAT
DEVELOPS STEM PROGRAMS FROM K
THROUGH 12 SCHOOL GLOBALLY. THIS
PROGRAM HAS GIVEN THESE SIERRA
STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXAMINE SEED GROWTH AND
GERMINATION IN SPACE AND STUDY
THE EFFECTS OF 3D PRINTING AND
MICROGRAVITY. SIERRA'S
INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION
PROGRAM TEAM IS A PRIME EXAMPLE
OF THE SCHOOL'S EFFORTS TO
STRENGTHEN STEM EDUCATION FOR
ALL STUDENTS, ESPECIALLY
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS, IN SOUTH
LOS ANGELES, DUE TO THEIR
GROUNDBREAKING WORK IN SCIENCE
EDUCATION, SIERRA IS NOW ONLY
THE THIRD SCHOOL ON THE PLANET
TO BE INVITED INTO THE X PRIZE,
WHICH IS THE WORLD'S LARGEST
SCIENCE COMPETITION. ALSO KNOWN
AS THE OLYMPICS OF SCIENCE.
THESE STUDENTS ARE MEMBERS OF
THE NATIONAL SOCIETY OF BLACK
ENGINEERS, BETTER KNOWN AS NSBE,
AND HAVE PARTNERED WITH THE US,
USC'S SCHOOL OF ENGINEERING AND
TWO OF THE SENIORS IN THE
PROGRAM HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED INTO
THE USC FOR THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS ON THIS TEAM,
AND ONE IS ALSO GOING TO
MOREHOUSE. THEY ARE INCREDIBLY
TALENTED SCHOLARS, AND IT'S A
PRIVILEGE TO HAVE THEM
RECOGNIZED ON THE SENATE TODAY,
THE STUDENTS JOINING US ON THE
FLOOR TODAY ARE CHRISTOPHER
HOBART, TRAVIS LEONARD, ISAIAH
DUNN, HENRY TOLAR, KEITH DAVEY,
JONATHAN CRUZ, SASHA LEVERETT.
LEVERETT, MITCHELL, MICHELLE
BAHENA AND ANDERSON PEACOCK.
MANY OF THEIR PARENTS WHO HAVE
TRAVELED TO BE HERE TODAY ARE
JOINING US IN THE GALLERY. I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE QUEST
INSTITUTE AND MR. KENNETH IRVINE
, WHO IS THE MENTOR, TEACHER AND
SCIENCE DEPARTMENT CHAIR AT
SIERRA HIGH SCHOOL WHO HAS
HELPED LEAD AND GUIDE THESE
STUDENTS EVERY STEP OF THEIR WAY
. MR. JOE CORMIER IS DIRECTOR OF
THE ADVANCEMENT FOR SIERRA, WHO
HELPED LEAD FUNDING FOR ALL
THESE PROGRAMS, AND MISS ANGELA
MATA. OH, I SAID I HAD THAT
READY MONSTER TO NANO PRINCIPAL
AND JUNIPER SIERRA, WHO'S
LEADERSHIP IS WHAT MAKES SIERRA
SUCH AN INCREDIBLE INSTITUTION
IN THE 35TH SENATE DISTRICT. AND
JUST LAST BUT NOT LEAST FOR SURE
IS JOHN MORAN, PRESIDENT OF
JUNIPERO SERRA HIGH SCHOOL, FOR
HIS COMMITMENT AND DEDICATION TO
PROVIDING UNDERSERVED STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA WITH A COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE IN TODAY'S SOCIETY.
MEMBERS, LET'S WELCOME THESE
YOUNG STUDENTS FROM JUNIPERO
SERRA HIGH SCHOOL.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
MEMBERS. YOU'RE WELCOME TO JOIN
A PHOTOGRAPH IN THE BACK
.
AND THANK YOU TO THE PARENTS FOR
BRINGING THEM ALL HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU. PARENTS.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. SENATOR ROTH AT THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 138 DECLARING APRIL
AS PARKINSON. ONE MINUTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 138 BY
SENATOR ROTH RELATIVE TO
PARKINSON'S AWARENESS MONTH.
SENATOR ROTH, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, DECLARING APRIL AS
PARKINSON'S AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA PARK HANSEN'S DISEASE
HAS TOUCHED MANY OF US IN SOME
WAY. I KNOW FOR MYSELF, IT'S
DEEPLY PERSONAL, AS MY FATHER
HAD PARKINSON'S DISEASE AND
ACTUALLY PASSED AWAY FROM ITS
COMPLICATIONS 32 YEARS AGO. AND
MY VERY, VERY GOOD AIR FORCE
FRIEND WAS RECENTLY DIAGNOSED.
HIS FATHER HAD IT, TOO.
PARKINSON'S DISEASE IS THE
SECOND MOST COMMON
NEURODEGENERATIVE DISEASE BEHIND
ALZHEIMER'S. CURRENTLY, THERE IS
NO KNOWN CURE OR DRUG TO SLOW OR
HALT THE PROGRESSION OF THE
DISEASE, AND AVAILABLE
TREATMENTS ARE LIMITED IN THEIR
ABILITY TO ADDRESS PATIENTS
MEDICAL NEEDS AND REMAIN
EFFECTIVE OVER TIME. THE
CALIFORNIA PARKINSON'S DISEASE
REGISTRY WAS CREATED IN 2017
THROUGH THE STATE BUDGET. THE
REGISTRY HAS BECOME A MODEL AS
IT COLLECTS PATIENT INFORMATION
THAT CAN HELP IMPROVE OUR
UNDERSTANDING AND TREATMENT OF
PARKINSON'S DISEASE. THE SPONSOR
OF THIS RESOLUTION, THE MICHAEL
J. FOX FOUNDATION FOR
PARKINSON'S RESEARCH, HAS RAISED
OVER $300 MILLION FOR
PARKINSON'S RESEARCH IN
CALIFORNIA, VÀ. AND IN 2010, THE
FOUNDATION LAUNCHED ITS LANDMARK
RESEARCH STUDY, THE PARKINSON'S
PROGRESSION MARKERS INITIATIVE
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND PARKINSON'S
AND ADVANCE NEW TREATMENTS. AS A
RESULT OF THIS STUDY, IN APRIL
2023, THE VALIDATION OF THE
FIRST EVER BIOMARKER FOR
PARKINSON'S DISEASE WAS
ANNOUNCED. FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
LIVING BODY, RESEARCHERS CAN
OBJECTIVELY DETECT AN ABNORMAL
PROTEIN IN INDIVIDUALS WITH
PARKINSON'S AND THOSE NOT YET
DIAGNOSED WITH PARKINSON'S WHO
DO NOT SHOW CLINICAL SYMPTOMS.
THIS IS CLEARLY AN AMAZING AND A
VERY MAJOR BREAKTHROUGH. IT HAS
BECOME ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT
INCREASED RESEARCH, EDUCATION
AND COMMUNITY SUPPORT SERVICES
ARE NEEDED TO FIND MORE
EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS AND TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO QUALITY CARE
FOR THOSE LIVING WITH THE
DISEASE. TODAY AND IT IS
CERTAINLY FITTING TO RECOGNIZE
APRIL AS PARKINSON'S AWARENESS
MONTH IN CALIFORNIA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 138. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GILL. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. AYE. NHIÀU AYE. OCHOA.
BORG. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
DURAZZO LIMON. NEWMAN. AYE STERN
. WILL CALL THE ROLE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ONE MORE TIME. ALLEN.
DURAZZO AYE. LIMON. STERN. 30
EYES, 37 NOES. ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. NOW UNDER
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR, SENATOR
ROTH. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING SOME KEY PARKINSON'S
ADVOCATES TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
JULIA PITCHER FROM THE MICHAEL
J. FOX FOUNDATION. MICHAEL
JAMISON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
NEURODEGENERATIVE DEGENERATIVE
DISEASE REGISTRY, AND KATRINA
TAYLOR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PARKINSON'S DISEASE REGISTRY.
HOW ABOUT A ROUND OF APPLAUSE?
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
OR IT'S STILL UNDER PRIVILEGE OF
THE FLOOR. SENATOR HURTADO,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE
TO INVITE YOU TO JOIN ME AFTER
SESSION IN CONFERENCE ROOM 7400,
IN THE SWING SPACE TO CELEBRATE
AGRICULTURE AND EARTH. WE WILL
HAVE TOMATO PLANTS AVAILABLE FOR
YOU TO TAKE AND CULTIVATE IN A
FRIENDLY COMPETITION TO SEE
WHICH SENATOR CAN GROW. THE
FIRST RED RIPE TOMATO. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES, AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING YOU IN ROOM 7400.
THANK YOU. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM FOR
MESSAGE FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED UNDER MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR APRIL 15TH, 2024 THROUGH
APRIL 13TH, EIGHTH, APRIL 18TH,
2024 WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE SENATE CLERK.
MEMBERS. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
JOINT RULE 62 A WILL BE WAIVED
FOR EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO HEAR
SENATE BILL 1435 WITHOUT FOUR
DAYS NOTICE IN THE DAILY FILE.
SENATOR BECKER, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO REMOVE FILE
ITEM A 46 AB 437 BY JACKSON FROM
THE INACTIVE FILE SO NOTED. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING DOWN TO
THE CONSIDERATION OF A DAILY
FILE. WE'RE AT SECOND READING
FILE. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1133 WITH AMENDMENTS
1414, WITH AMENDMENTS 1210, WITH
AMENDMENTS 993, WITH AMENDMENTS
1118, WITH AMENDMENTS 1298, WITH
AMENDMENTS 1413, WITH AMENDMENTS
. ALL RIGHT. NOW MOVING TO
SENATE. THIRD READING. WE HAVE
TWO ITEMS. FIRST UP IS FILE ITEM
42. SENATOR DODD IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION TEN BY SENATOR
DODD, RELATIVE TO THE BERRYESSA
SNOW MOUNTAIN NATIONAL MONUMENT
EXPANSION ACT. SENATOR DODD,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS SA TEN URGES THE
PRESIDENT TO USE EXISTING
AUTHORITY GRANTED BY THE
ANTIQUITIES ACT TO EXPAND THE
BERRYESSA SNOW MOUNTAIN NATIONAL
MONUMENT AND CONGRESS TO PASS
HOUSE BILL 1396 AND SENATE BILL
683, BOTH THESE MEASURES WOULD
RENAME WALKER RIDGE TO MOORLACH
LU█N, WHICH MEANS CONDOR RIDGE
IN THE PATWIN LANGUAGE.
ADDITIONALLY, THEY WOULD ALSO
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN THE TRIBES.
BUREAU OF LAND MANAGEMENT AND
THE US FOREST SERVICE. BY
EXPANDING THIS NATIONAL
MONUMENT, WE ARE PROTECTING
SACRED TRIBAL LANDS AND CRITICAL
HABITAT FOR WILDLIFE AND ALSO
IMPROVING ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS
AND HELPING TO CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA'S GOAL OF PROTECTING
30% OF LANDS AND WATERS BY 2030.
THE RESOLUTION IS A NECESSARY
STEP IN URGING STEADFAST ACTION
ON THIS NEEDED EXPANSION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. HEARING
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 42
ALAN ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE Ã.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER I BLAKE.
SPEAR I. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLASER I. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD AYE. LEMON MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. WHEN NILO. OCHOA. BOGH.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ADAM. DALLEY. GROVE
AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE. WHEN? AYE.
NILO AYE. OCHOA AYE. STERN.
BUT ALL RIGHT. ICE 35 NOES!
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 46. SENATOR WAHAB, PLEASE.
PREPARED SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 133
BY SENATOR WAHAB, RELATIVE TO
AMERICAN MUSLIM APPRECIATION AND
AWARENESS MONTH, SENATOR WAHAB,
THANK YOU, PRESIDENTS AND
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TO PRESENT
SCR 133 AMERICAN MUSLIM
APPRECIATION AND AWARENESS
MONTH. I'M PROUD TO BE PART OF
THIS RACIALLY, ETHNICALLY, AND
CULTURALLY DIVERSE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY. IT HAS HISTORICALLY
BEEN OBSERVED IN AUGUST, BUT THE
COMMUNITY WOULD LIKE TO BE FOR
IT TO MOVE IN APRIL IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT MORE INCLUSIVE
PROGRAMING. NOW, I CAN SAY WE
ARE BUSINESS OWNERS, LEGAL
PROFESSIONALS, DOCTORS,
ENGINEERS, TEACHERS, FARMERS,
HUMANITARIANS, ATHLETES,
COMEDIANS, MUSICIANS,
FILMMAKERS, ARTISTS AND POLICY
MAKERS WHICH WE ARE, BUT WE ARE
HUMAN BEINGS. FIRST AND
DESERVING OF RESPECT AND DIGNITY
. WE MUSLIMS ARE DIVERSE, WITH
OVER 1 BILLION AND GROWING IN
THE WORLD, WITH THE FASTEST
GROWING DEMOGRAPHIC BEING LATINO
. WE ARE ALSO DIVERSE IN HOW WE
PRACTICE OUR FAITH. SOME OF US
FAST, SOME OF US DON'T. SOME OF
US ARE MORE MODEST, SOME OF US
AREN'T. SOME PRAY FIVE TIMES A
DAY. SOME DON'T PRAY AT ALL. BUT
ALL OF US BELIEVE IN PEACE,
COMPASSION, AND A COMMITMENT TO
COMMUNITY. WHILE INCIDENTS OF
HATE CONTINUE TO IMPACT THE
MUSLIM COMMUNITY, WE CONTINUE TO
SHOW OUR RESILIENCE AND THRIVE.
YET THIS IS A REPEATED STORY.
YOU YEARS AGO, I WORKED WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BILL QUIRK TO
HAVE AN AMERICAN MUSLIM
APPRECIATION AND AWARENESS
MONTH, WHICH HAS AGAIN
TRADITIONALLY BEEN HONORED IN
AUGUST AND WHEN HE INTRODUCED
THIS, HE RECEIVED DEATH THREATS
FOR DOING THIS RESOLUTION. THIS
IS UN-AMERICAN, AND I'M SICK AND
TIRED OF HAVING TO KEEP SPEAKING
UP TO SAY MUSLIMS ARE PEOPLE,
TOO. MUSLIMS ARE AMERICANS.
MUSLIMS DESERVE TO BE TREATED
WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT. AND
YET TIME AND TIME AGAIN, I'VE
STOOD UP TO SPEAK UP FOR THIS
COMMUNITY, AN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
THAT HAS BEEN PART OF AN
AMERICAN HISTORY SINCE BLACK
MUSLIM SLAVES WERE BROUGHT TO
THIS NATION BEFORE IT WAS
OFFICIALLY FOUNDED. I'VE STOOD
UP FOR VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
FIRST AND FOREMOST. AFTER
HEARING COMMENTS THAT ARE
DEGRADING TO THEM ON THIS FLOOR.
BUT WITH THE MUSLIM COMMUNITY, I
STILL SEE THIS COMMUNITY LEFT
OUT ON THEIR OWN TO FEND FOR
THEMSELVES. I'M PUBLICLY SAYING
THIS. I'M EXPECTING EVERYONE TO
STEP UP FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. WHETHER YOU BELONG
TO IT OR NOT. IT IS THE AMERICAN
THING TO DO. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR MIN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
ASIAN AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS, I
TOO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SCR 133.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM HAYWARD FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. THE AMERICAN MUSLIM
COMMUNITY ACCOUNTS FOR 3.45
MILLION PEOPLE IN OUR NATION,
OVER 500,000 PEOPLE. RIGHT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. IN OUR STATE
ALONE, WE HAVE OVER 200 DIVERSE
MOSQUES, RELIGIOUS CENTERS AND
COMMUNITY INSTITUTIONS WHICH ADD
TO THE RICH TAPESTRY OF
DIVERSITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY, AS MY COLLEAGUE
EXPRESSED IT, MAKES INCREDIBLY
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
CULTURE, TO OUR LABOR FORCE,
WITH ABOUT 8% OF THE MUSLIM
POPULATION BEING SELF-EMPLOYED
AND EACH MUSLIM BUSINESS OWNER
PROVIDING JOBS ON AVERAGE OF
EIGHT PER BUSINESS, SUPPORTING
AN ESTIMATED 1.37 MILLION TOTAL
JOBS IN THE UNITED STATES. AT A
TIME WHEN ISLAMOPHOBIA AND
ANTI-MUSLIM SENTIMENTS GENERALLY
ARE ON THE RISE, INCLUDING, WE
SAW A FEW YEARS BACK, AN
ATTEMPTED MUSLIM BAN PREVENTING
PEOPLE FROM TRAVELING. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE FIGHT AGAINST
ALL DISCRIMINATION AND STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH OUR MUSLIM
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. SO TODAY,
I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS ENCOURAGES
EVERYONE TO JOIN WITH OUR MUSLIM
AMERICAN FRIENDS AND URGE YOU TO
VOTE AYE AND SUPPORT THE VIBRANT
CONTRIBUTIONS CULTURE AND
HERITAGE OF THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SENATOR WAHAB, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE. THANK YOU.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEAR. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
NILO. AYE. OTOBO AYE. BADIA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. ON A VOTE
OF 37 TO 0, THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THIS IS THE TIME TO
ADDRESS ADJOURN IN MEMORY
MOTIONS. FIRST, WANT TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR BRADFORD?
THANK YOU, MISTER PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF A FRIEND. A FRIEND
THAT I DID NOT KNOW THAT LONG,
BUT WHO MADE A TREMENDOUS IMPACT
ON ME IN THE SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME THAT WE GOT TO KNOW EACH
OTHER. THAT IN THE PERSON OF
TERRENCE TROY DASHER, WHO PASSED
AWAY ON FEBRUARY 24 AT THE
TENDER AGE OF 55. TROY WAS A
BUSINESS TRAILBLAZER, A POWERFUL
ORATOR, A PILLAR OF CORPORATE
AMERICA AND THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THIS NATION. HE WAS BORN
IN PELL CITY, ALABAMA IN 1968
AND WAS A STUDENT AT GETTYSBURG
COLLEGE, WHERE HE GRADUATED AND
LATER ON SERVED ON THE BOARD
UNTIL THE TIME OF HIS PASSING.
AS A YOUNG MAN, TROY WAS AN
EXCELLENT STUDENT AND
PARTICIPATED IN MANY ACTIVITIES
IN AND OUT OF SCHOOL. HE WAS A
MEMBER OF THE BETA CLUB, FUTURE
FARMERS OF AMERICA, THE STATE
CHAMPIONSHIP TRACK TEAM, AND IN
THE MARCHING BAND WHERE HE WAS A
FANTASTIC DRUMMER. HE WAS A DJ
FOR HIS CAMPUS RADIO STATION,
THE PRESIDENT OF THE BLACK
STUDENT UNION, AND ONE OF THE
FIRST BLACK STUDENT BODY
SENATORS AT HIS UNIVERSITY.
TROY'S BUSINESS CAREER SPANNED
MANY INDUSTRIES AND EVENTUALLY
LED HIM TO OAKLAND, CALIFORNIA.
HE WORKED WITH PROCTER AND
GAMBLE, WOOD BROTHERS, AND JTG
RACING AND THE CLOROX
CORPORATION, AND LET ME GO BACK
TO JT, G RACING. HE WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST AND ONLY
AFRICAN-AMERICAN PERSONS TO WORK
IN THIS SPACE AND ADVERTISING
ALL THE CORPORATE COMPANIES YOU
SEE ATTACHED TO STOCK CAR RACING
TODAY. HE HAD A LOT TO DO WITH
THAT, AND HE MADE A VOLUNTARY
DECISION TO LEAVE, HIS CORPORATE
JOB AT CORPORATE AND GAMBLE TO
DO SUCH AND PROMOTE ADVERTISING
OF COMPANIES AND STOCK CAR
RACING, AS STATED, HE WORKED AT
PROCTER AND GAMBLE, THE WOODS
BROTHERS AND CLOROX. HE WORKED
FOR 20 YEARS AT CLOROX AND
REACHED THE PINNACLE OF HIS
CAREER IN 19. I MEAN, 2019 TÍNH,
WHEN HE WAS NAMED SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT AND CHIEF CUSTOMER
OFFICER RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
COMPANY'S WORLDWIDE SALES
ORGANIZATION, HE WAS ONLY TWO
AFRICAN AMERICANS TO EVER REACH
THE C-SUITE AT CLOROX, AND HE
VOLUNTARILY LEFT IN 2021 WHEN HE
MADE HISTORY AND BECAME THE
FIRST BLACK CALIFORNIA EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AND CHAIRMAN OF A MAJOR
PUBLICLY TRADED CANNABIS
COMPANY. AS CEO OF THE PARENT
COMPANY, TROY WAS HONORED TO BE
AT THE FOREFRONT OF SHAPING THE
FUTURE OF THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
IT WAS THROUGH THIS INDUSTRY
THAT I WAS ABLE TO MEET HIM IN
2023, AT THE NATIONAL 21. I
SHOULD SAY, AT THE NATIONAL,
CAUCUS OF STATE LEGISLATORS.
WHEN WE SAT ON A PANEL, HE
DISRUPTED A SECTOR THAT HAD BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR, AND HE
HELPED CREATE A INDUSTRY THAT
WAS ROOTED IN DIVERSITY, EQUITY
AND JUSTICE. HE BELIEVED IN
GIVING BACK TO HIS COMMUNITY,
ESPECIALLY YOUTH. HIS ALMA
MATER, GETTYSBURG COLLEGE, AND
THE YOUNG BLACK EXECUTIVES. TROY
BUILT A LEGACY BASED ON LOVE FOR
HIS FAMILY, FRIENDS, HOMETOWN
AND EVERYONE WHO IS BLESSED TO
KNOW HIM. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
DEVOTED WIFE, SHANNON, AND HIS
DAUGHTER NIA, WHICH I WAS
PRIVILEGED TO MEET HIS MOTHER
AND FATHER, MARGARET AND ERNEST,
AND MANY BROTHERS AND SISTERS,
NIECES, NEPHEWS, COUSINS AND
FRIENDS. HE WILL BE TRULY MISSED
BY ALL THAT KNEW HIM BY
CORPORATE AMERICA. AND MEMBERS,
HELP ME ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
A REAL JEDI WARRIOR, A WARRIOR
FOR JUSTICE, EQUITY, DIVERSION,
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BRADFORD. SENATE EXTENDS ITS
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN THE SENATE
JOURNAL. AS WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY. NEXT UP, SENATOR DURAZZO
. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES IT IS WITH SADNESS
THAT I ASK WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF DISTINGUISHED
COMMUNITY LAWYER FRED TSUNEO
NAKAMURA, PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE
OF 71, DEDICATING MORE THAN 40
YEARS TO COMMUNITY STEWARDSHIP.
HE LEAVES BEHIND A LASTING
LEGACY OF JUSTICE THAT HAS
PROFOUNDLY TOUCHED THE LIVES OF
HIS CLIENTS, COLLEAGUES AND
THOSE WHO ADMIRE AND RESPECT
HIM. HE WAS BORN IN OKINAWA,
JAPAN. HE MOVED TO THE UNITED
STATES, WHERE HE EARNED HIS
DEGREE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
WASHINGTON. ENCOURAGED BY
ATTORNEYS AT PUMA, PIMA COUNTY
LEGAL AID IN SOUTHERN ARIZONA,
WHERE HE VOLUNTEERED AS A SENIOR
CITIZEN OUTREACH PARALEGAL. HE
WENT ON TO COMPLETE HIS JD AT
PEOPLE'S COLLEGE OF LAW IN LOS
ANGELES. WHILE WORKING WITH THE
NATIONAL LAWYERS GUILD IN TENANT
ACTION CENTERS. FOLLOWING
GRADUATION, HE BEGAN HIS LEGAL
PROFESSION WITH NEIGHBORHOOD
LEGAL SERVICES OF LOS ANGELES,
WHERE HE WAS KNOWN AND
APPRECIATED FOR HIS COMPASSION
AND ADVOCACY. WHILE REPRESENTING
TENANTS IN SOME OF LA'S POOREST
NEIGHBORHOODS. FRED OFTEN
BROUGHT A CAMERA AND A TOOLBOX
TO HIS CLIENTS HOMES, THE FIRST
TO DOCUMENT THEIR PROBLEMS AND
THE SECOND TO TRY AND FIX THEM.
HAVING JOINED LEGAL AID
FOUNDATION OF LOS ANGELES AS A
STAFF ATTORNEY IN ITS EVICTION
DEFENSE CENTER, FRED LATER
RETURNED TO LEGAL SERVICES,
WHERE HE SERVED WITH HIS
CHARACTERISTIC DEDICATION, SENSE
OF CONCERN, AND AS ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF LITIGATION AND
POLICY UNTIL HE RETIRED IN 2022.
OVER THE COURSE OF HIS CAREER,
HE EARNED A STELLAR REPUTATION
AS AN EXPERT IN EVICTION,
DEFENSE, RENT CONTROL,
RELOCATION ASSISTANCE, FEDERALLY
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING, AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT, HOMEOWNER
FRAUD, AND MOBILE HOME ISSUES.
HE SERVED HIS COMMUNITY BY
PROVIDING DIRECT SERVICES, WORK
IMPACT LITIGATION, AND POLICY
ADVOCACY. FRED TRAINED AND
MENTORED HUNDREDS OF LAWYERS,
FOR WHICH HE WAS ACKNOWLEDGED
WITH NUMEROUS HONORS. HE WILL BE
CELEBRATED AND REMEMBERED FOR
FAR MORE THAN JUST HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AS A
COMPASSIONATE LAWYER, AS HE
LEAVES BEHIND A LEGACY OF A
CARING COMMUNITY MEMBER. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS SIBLINGS BOB,
GEORGE, ROY, CATHY, AND LINDA,
NEPHEWS AND EXTENDED FAMILIES
AND CLOSE FRIENDS. REST IN
POWER, BROTHER FRED, YOU WILL BE
MISSED. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DURAZO. THE SENATE EXTENDS ITS
CONDOLENCES TO MR. NAKAMURA AS
MANY FRIENDS AND FAMILY, PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
SENATE JOURNAL AS WE ADJOURN. IN
HIS MEMORY, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. FIRST
UP, SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. THE MILITARY AND
VETERANS COMMITTEE WILL ROOM
IMMEDIATELY AFTER ADJOURNMENT IN
ROOM 113113 HERE IN THE CAPITOL.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ARCHULETA.
NEXT UP, SENATOR BLAKE SPEER.
THANK YOU. THE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION IN ROOM
ONE, ONE, TWO OF THE CAPITOL
HERE IN THE CAPITOL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BLAKE SPEER.
SENATOR BRADFORD, THANK YOU.
UPON ADJOURNMENT, THE SENATE
ENERGY AND UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATION COMMITTEE WILL
MEET IN ROOM 1200 AND SWING
SPACE. SENATOR ROTH, THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WILL MEET IN ROOM 2215
MINUTES AFTER ADJOURNMENT. THANK
YOU. SENATOR ROTH. IF THERE'S NO
OTHER BUSINESS BEFORE THE
SENATE, SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE
DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. AND AGAIN
TO SENATOR WILK, SENATOR
PORTANTINO, SENATOR DURAZZO AND
ALL OF THE MEMBERS AND
COMMEMORATING ARMENIAN GENOCIDE
DAY. THANK YOU. THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THURSDAY, APRIL 25TH AT 9 A.M.
THANK YOU, SENATOR MCGUIRE. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
3:30 P.M, AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT 9
A.M.